Act now.
BE ONE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
REPORTEDLY IS ROLLING BACK A
TRUMP-ERA POLICY THAT PUNISHED
SO-CALLED SANCTUARY CITIES THAT
REFUSED TO COOPERATE WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES,
THOSE CITIES FOUNDED MORE THAN
TWO DOZEN STATES WILL NO LONGER
BE REQUIRED TO WORK WITH
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT TO GET ACCESS TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TAXPAYER MONEY.
SO KAYLEIGH, I COME TO YOU FIRST
ON THIS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY DURING
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
IS ANOTHER ROLLBACK OF YET
ANOTHER POLICY, IT DIDN’T GO
WELL WITH THE BORDER POLICIES
THAT JOE BIDEN HAS ROLLBACK,
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS ONE COME
UP WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL
HAPPEN?
>> Kayleigh: A COMPLETELY
LAWLESS AND DERELICT IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN, WE
ARE NOW BECOMING A SANCTUARY
COUNTRY AND PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE
THAT EMINENTLY CLEAR WHEN HE
RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE IN JANUARY
SAID "I AM ISSUING A 100 A
MORATORIUM ON DEPORTATIONS" ONLY
TO BE REBUKED BY A FEDERAL JUDGE
WHO SAIDID YOU CAN’T DO THAT BUT
NEVERTHELESS, THEY ARE NOT
ARRESTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS AT THE
SAME RATE AS PRESIDENT TRUMP,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN DECEMBER,
4,400 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS WERE
ARRESTED, COMPARE THAT TO 1900
IN MARCH HUNTER BIDEN, THEY ARE
ALLOWING CRIMINALS TO ALLOW
LESLIE TAKE TO OUR STREETS, GANG
MEMBERS IN JAIL TO BE RELEASED
WITHOUT GETTING THE NECESSARY
ROTATION TO ICE TO PROTECT
INNOCENT, BEAUTIFUL GIRLS LIKE
KATE STANLEY WHO SHOULD BE HERE
WITH US TODAY IF IT WERE NOT FOR
LAWLESS IMMIGRATION POLICIES.
>> Harris: IT IS BEYOND THOSE
HEARTBREAKING FACTS AND THE
LOSSES OF LOVED ONES, SO ON AND
SO FORTH WITH THOSE CRIMES BEING
COMMITTED, IT’S ALSO DRUG CARTEL
MEMBERS, WHEN YOU TALK TO
ATTORNEYS GENERAL AS FAR NORTH
FROM THE BORDER OF MONTANA WHAT
YOU LEARN IS THAT THEY ARE
SEEING A HUGE BURST IN CRIME
WITH THE BORDER SITUATION AS IT
IS NOW AND IF YOU BEGIN TO
PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE CRIMINALLY
INFILTRATING OUR GREAT CITIES
ACROSS AMERICA, AS WE ALL DO, WE
KNOW IMMIGRATION, LEGAL
IMMIGRATION HAS MADE US GREAT
COUNTRY, THEY ARE HERE FOR
COMPLETELY OPPOSITE REASONS.
AND IF YOU LOSE THE ABILITY TO
GO AFTER THOSE PEOPLE, DO YOU
MAKE A AMERICA LESS SAFE?
>> Larry: THIS IS NO SURPRISE,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT THEYY FELT THE
TRUMP POLICIES TOWARD SANCTUARY
CITIES WAS RACIST AND HE WAS
GOING TO REVERSE IT PAID WHAT I
FIND INTERESTING IS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CLEARLY HAVE
DEDETERMINED THAT THIS IS A
POSITIVE POLITICAL CALCULUS FOR
THEM, THEY FEEL THAT EVENTUALLY
ILLEGAL ALIENS TURNED VOTERS
WILL VOTE FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT THEY DO
THIS AT THE RISK OF ALIENATING
BLACK VOTERS, THE HARVARD
ECONOMIST THAT’S PROBABLY DONE
MORE WORK ON THE IMPACT OF LEGAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND MANY
OTHER ECONOMIST AND ONE OF THE
BIG LOSERS HE SAID ARE UNSKILLED
BLACK AND BROWN WORKERS IN THE
INNER-CITY THAT HAD TO COMPLETE
FOR JOBS THAT ARE HELD BY
ILLEGAL ALIENS THAT PUT DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON THEIR WAGES SO THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE DETERMINED THEY
DON’T CARE, DON’T KNOW OR WON’T
BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT THE DAMAGE
THAT UNBRIDLED, UNSKILLED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION DOES TO THEM
THEM.
B1 JENNA, YOUR RESPONSE TO WHAT
LARRY ELDER JUST SAID?
>> Jenna: WELL, AGAIN, I COME
BACK TO EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE, ARE
WE TALKING ABOUT THE FUNDS THAT
ARE NOW BEING RELEASED TO MAJOR
CITIES AROUND THE COUNTRY,
GRANTS, SPECIFICALLY IN HONOR OF
AN OFFICER WHO WAS KILLED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY THAT IS THERE TO
SUPPORT THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
HELP WITH PROSECUTION, TO HELP
IN COMMUNITY BUILDING, SO THE
IRONY OF THIS VERY SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION ABOUT FUND’S BEING
RE-R-RELEASED TO THE CITIES IS
THAT THERE IS POLICY REQUEST
FROM PARTS OF THE LEFT TO DEFUND
THE POLICE AND THEN THERE’S FROM
THE RIGHT SAYING HOW COULD THIS
POSSIBLY BE?
AND HERE WE ARE DEBATING THE
FACT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
RELEASED RESOURCES TO GO
SPECIFICALLY TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SUPPORT, AGAIN, EVERYTHING
FROM MENTAL HEALTH THE
PROSECUTION SO IF YOU WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION, THIS
PARTICULAR RELEASE OF RESOURCES
IS SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Harris: I WANT TO COME BACK
TO YOU, LARRY, AND GET YOUR
REBUTTAL ON THAT.
>> Larry: THIS IS A BROAD
CONVERSATION THAT APPARENTLY SHE
DOESN’T WANT TO HAVE, THE
QUESTION IS, ARE WE A NATION OF
LAWS OR ARE WE A NATION OF
LAWLESSNESS?
THERE’S NO QUESTION THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE THE
DETERMINATION AS HAVE PEOPLE
LIKE, YOU CAN GO ONLINE AND LOOK
AT HIS 2009 SPEECH WHERE HE
SAID, IF WE CAN GET 11 MILLION
PEOPLE ON A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP, 2 OUT OF 3 WILL
VOTE FOR US AND WE WILL HAVE A
GOVERNING COALITION FOR THE LONG
HAUL, THIS IS A CALCULATION
THEY’VE MADE, THERE’S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
IF IT WERE TRUE THAT ILLEGAL
ALIENS TURNED CITIZENS WOULD
VOTE REPUBLICAN WE WOULD NOT BE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION ANYMORE
THEN WE BE HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT D.C. STATEHOOD OR
PUERTO RICAN STATEHOOD, WE WOULD
NOT BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
IF THIS DIDN’T POLITICALLY
BENEFIT DEMOCRATS.
PLEASE ADMIT THAT.
BEFORE LATELY, I WILL
SPECIFICALLY ECHO EXACTLY WHAT
KAYLEIGH SAID BEFORE YOU WHEN
SHE SAID, ARE WE A SANCTUARY
COUNTRY?
A FAMILY REMINDER TO MOST FOLKS
THAT IN FACT THIS COUNTRY HAS
SERVED AS A SANCTUARY FOR SO
MANY OF OUR ANCESTORS.
AND LET ME JUST SAY, KAYLEIGH,
YOU CAN’T KEEP THROWING DOWN
MS-13, AND MAKING STATEMENTS,
I’M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THE
VICTIMS OR THEIR STRATEGIES
AREN’T REAL BUT MAKING BROAD
SWEEPING STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO THIS
BORDER, IT’S AN EASY NARRATIVE
AND LARRY, RELATED TO THE
LAWLESSNESS, I DRIVE THE SPEED
LIMIT, SO WE ARE A COUNTRY OF
LAWS.
>> Harris: I DO WANT TO CLEAN
SOMETHING UP THAT YOU JUST SAID,
I MADE IT VERY CLEAR WHO WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF COMING
ACROSS THAT BORDER, NO ONE ON
THIS PANEL HAS SAID IT IS THE
MAJORITY, THE LARGE NUMBER, ALL
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT, WHAT I
SAID THAT THIS COUNTRY IS AS
GREAT AS IT IS BECAUSE OF THE
LEGAL IMMIGRATION WE HAVE SEEN
AND WHAT WE SEE IS US URGENCY
AMONG THE FEW WHO COME INTO OUR
CITIES AND GO AS FAR NORTH AS
MONTANA AND OTHER PLACES WHEN
YOU TALK TO THEIR ATTORNEYS
GENERAL, THEY WILL TELL YOU THAT
THE CRIME IS BURSTING AS THEY
ARE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER, I
DON’T WANT YOU TO PAINT THIS AS
KAYLEIGH OR ANYBODY ELSE HAS
MADE ANY SUGGESTION, EVEN THAT
THIS IS ALL PEOPLE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER.
NO ONE HAS SAID THAT, NO ONE
BELIEVES THAT.
>> Jenna: I’M GLAD WE ARE ON
THE SAME PAGE.
>> Harris: I LAID THAT UP
BEFORE ANYBODY EVEN TALKS VERY
QUICKLY, WANTS TO WRAP, EMILY?
>> Emily: YES, PLEASE, TO
RESPOND TO JENNA’S COMMENT,
SHE’S RIGHT, IN HONOR OF A
FALLEN OFFICER, IT GOES TO
INITIATIVES THAT ARE WITHIN
LAW ENFORCEMENT, PROSECUTION,
CORRECTION, MENTAL HEALTH AND
DRUG PROGRAMS SO IN 2020 IT WAS
ABOUT $253 MILLION AND MY POINT
IS THAT THAT IS THE ARENA,
LAW ENFORCEMENT MEANS
LAW ENFORCEMENT SO IF YOU WANT A
LAW TO NOT EXIST IT NEEDS TO BE
LEGISLATIVELY CHANGED AND IT’S
FOR THAT SOCIETY AND WHEN YOU
REMOVE THE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
AGENCIES, WHEN YOU REWEWARD
STOPPING THAT COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES THE SUFFERING,
THOSE ARE THE VICTIMS.
THOSE ARE THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO DON’T BENEFIT FROM
OTHERWISE WHAT WOULD BE AN
UPTICK IN ACTUAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND SOLVING OF CRIMES.
HE LITERALLY JUST PASSED A BUNCH
OF LAWS THAT GO TOWARD UPTICKS
OF ENCOURAGING COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN AGENCIES, THAT’S HOW
CRIMES ARE SOLVED, TAKE IT FOR
ME AS A CRIMINAL ATTORNEY, IT
REALLY UNDERSCORES THE NEED FOR
THE COMMUNICATIONS OF A
REWARDING THAT IT’S NOT ABOUT
PIVOTING TO A QUESTION OF
IMMIGRATION ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, IT’S PIVOTING OR
ENCOMPASSING THE QUESTION OF
ACTUAL COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
AGENCIES IN THE CRIMINAL SECTOR
WHEN YOU DON’T LET FEDERAL
AGENCIES COMMUNICATE WITH LOCAL
AGENCIES WHEN THEY HAVE SLIPPED
OUT FOR THESE GUYS THAT HAVE
BROKEN THE LAW AND THAT’S A